borders and across countries and on that
note I would just say let's watch out
for protectionism protectionism is not
the solution to the few issues that are
serious but yet we should not reverse
history thank you very much
trust and long-term Partnerships trust
and long-term partnership and believe it
or not the only thing I get graded on is
ending on time and we are exactly at the
end of our time so please put your hands
together for this fantastic
thank you very much
thank you thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
not just as
industry insiders as well to what's
happened over the last 12 months they
also have Decades of experience when it
comes to the energy industry and they
will be responsible in many ways for
what happens next
I want to welcome my panelist prime
minister margarita
the president of Tanzania as well Samia
Hassan welcome Madam president
um the senator from West Virginia
Mr Joe manchin Francesco sarasi the
chief executive officer and general
manager of enol as well as Elam Cadre
the CEO and chairman of the executive
committee of Solvay
and kirstarmer leader of the opposition
of the United Kingdom
it seems like a good place to kick it
off because when we think about what's
been happening
across the world energy poverty today is
a major major problem in the United
Kingdom some 6.7 million people are
having trouble making ends meet
according to the polls Mr Stormer you
could very well be the next prime
minister of the United Kingdom what is
the plan
uh well look you're absolutely right at
the moment the central focus is on the
cost of living in the energy price
because we all know what's happened 2022
was quite an extraordinary year and
what's happened in the UK is a
short-term response to that so we have
caps Frozen energy bills for the vast
majority of people across the country
and we've funded that with a form of
windfall tax on oil and gas companies
particularly in the North Sea but that
is only a short-term solution it's a
what I call sticking plaster solution
what we need is a strategy
for Renewables that binds together
the challenge of High bills
energy security so that we're not so
exposed globally to Putin or whatever
the next generation of jobs that will
come as we rush towards Renewables
and our obligations in relation to the
climate
um crisis and that requires all
countries including my own to show
Global Leadership in this to bring
countries together we've seen some
examples of that you see what's going on
in America see the early evidence of
what's going on in Europe we need that
in the UK as well and that's why but at
our party conference in the Autumn of
last year we set our plans for what we
call our green Prosperity plan
um going towards clean power generation
by 2030 and that's ambitious that means
and here and Davos has been an
opportunity for me to speak to many CEOs
of businesses and investors who would
partner us if we're in government to do
that but it also requires
um Global Leadership and
um one of the things that I am proposing
is a clean power lion where countries
that are in the advance when it comes to
Net Zero share
information cooperate
and share investment with a view to
driving the global prices down so this
is an inverse OPEC if you like instead
of trying to you know ensure prices stay
at a certain level it's to drive them
down to see the common benefit whether
it's in the UK or across the globe and
if we could get that Alliance working
together then I think that will be a big
step in the right direction well
speaking of OPEC yesterday on CNBC I
spoke exclusively with I'm a NASA of the
CEO of Saudi aramco and one of the
things that he told me was that he
wasn't so worried about 2023 but he's
much more worried about the medium to
long term when it comes to spare
capacity in the oil markets and just to
clarify for our viewers are you prepared
to encourage investment in oil and gas
as well as Renewables what we've said
about oil and gas is there does need to
be a transition obviously it will play
its part during that transition but not
new investment not new Fields up in the
North Sea because we need to go towards
net zero we need to ensure that
renewable energy is where we go next
there's huge potential for this in the
UK in terms of wind and offshore wind
we're already
developing that speed we need onshore
wind to go with it so that
um
we
have a combination that as I say brings
the prices down
gets us off
the international Reliance on oil and
gas
and with it gives us the next generation
of jobs and deals with the climate
crisis and we that's why we set a
stretch Target of 2030 for clean power
generation that's where we want to get
to so yes
um a role for oil and gas as we
transition but no to new investment
because we've got to take this decision
that's going to require leadership so no
new oil investment or gas investment in
the North Sea yes
I want to pick up on something we heard
yesterday from the former Vice President
of the United States Al Gore he was
talking about climate change and he made
some pretty
strong statements he talked about
boiling oceans and Rain bombs Senator
manchin when you hear that kind of
rhetoric do you believe that that is
helpful to the conversation it's not
it's not factual it's not basically
realistic to what's what's going on in
the world right now let me just say that
there's been a lot of consternation and
concerns about the IRA inflation
reduction act thinking that it's going
to harm the EU there's no intent
whatsoever to harm any of our allies and
basically to be able to give them the
assurance that we're always going to be
there well we've been blessed in the
United States we have the resources we
have oil we have natural gas we have the
ability from technology to do everything
we can to promote the new technologies
of the future what we're not going to do
in the United States is get rid of get
rid of something until we have something
that'll do exactly what we're getting
rid of and do it as well if not better
we will not do that we will not leave
ourselves in a vacant position we think
our friends in the EU basically are are
challenged right now and we weren't even
able to help you the first thing our
Administration said was well let's go
out and see if we can get Iran we'll
lift the sanctions I said the most
prolific terrorists in the world you're
going to give them money to do more
happy can wreak havoc around the world
absolutely not with my vote and then
they talked about uh well let's uh you
know and I understand Venezuela and then
working with our friends in the gulf and
all that let me tell you in the United
States right now we are 12.4 million
barrels a day we're going to go to 13.
we can go to 15 million barrels a day
we've produced over 35 trillion cubic
feet of gas last year we're we're
basically exporting LNG at about 14 uh
the 35 trillion cubic feet but we're
exporting on LNG 14 billion cubic feet
we're going to take that to 25 billion
cubic feet to make sure that you all in
the EU do not run out of the assurance
that the United States will be there to
help now by I'm saying all of that we're
doing it cleaner than ever before carbon
capture sequestration utilization
methane capturing we have to have the
horsepower of fossil use a cleaner than
anywhere in the world and then also
we'll have records amounts of investment
that's going to go into clean technology
hydrogen small modular reactors all the
different things and Renewables we're
doing everything we can with Renewables
but we're putting an awful lot of
investment into storage so we can have
it more dispatchable when we need it
here's the difference between the United
States and I see what what's happened
for the last 10 years 12 years I've been
in the Senate I was the governor of the
state of West Virginia before they have
said well you got to have carbon pricing
you have a carbon tax
and I said are you people crazy you
think I'm going to add to inflation by
adding more cost what we did was good
for incentives with Investments and now
we're drawing attention from the whole
world to come to the United States to
invest we're trying to reduce the amount
of risk you're going to have and trying
to mature these new technologies so if
you really want
a clean environment a cleaner
environment and geopolitical you know
basically some calming of geopolitical
unrest that we have you better be able
to do a quicker faster and better than
any place in the world and and share it
with your friends that's what we're
going to do the senator mentioned um I
just want to mention for our audience
who may be unaware
um I believe that the oil and gas
community in the United States
contributed some at a hundred and eighty
thousand dollars to your last campaign
uh which isn't by the way illegal
because I'm not a state of them I'm
hoping they're supporting me yeah
laughs
that because the bottom line is you tell
me I mean look right now weaponized
energy we didn't do a thing we set back
we also what we're going to do our
friends and all of our allies were
hurting
and we couldn't come to your rescue
quick enough we're ramping up now and
we're going to do it better and quicker
and we're proud of that and we're going
to transition but we're not removing
something until we have something better
we won't do that
prime minister Wayne on on this on the
inflation reduction act because
obviously right now the folks in
Brussels are working diligently to find
out some kind of response in your mind
did this undermine the relationship no
but but first of all we we have for
years
told the US you have to step up on Paris
you have to step up on climate change
now they're doing it this is basically
the inflation there's a bit of a strange
title I would have called it differently
but I'm not a senator in the U.S but it
legislation itself was aimed to close
the gap on the Paris climate agreement
so let's be happy about it but then
there are I believe unintended
consequences and we are extensively uh
in talks with the US bilaterally also to
the European Union to make sure that
those unintended consequences don't have
the effect we are afraid they could have
and that is being done at the moment I
must myself uh Tuesday last Tuesday was
President Biden I know the European
commission is working very hard on this
I'm not really pessimistic I think we
can get somewhere where it won't hurt
rival day after second world war support
us with the Marshall Plan now to put in
legislation which is hurting the
European Union
I'm not sure that everybody in the U.S
was aware that there is not a free trade
agreement with Europe uh I'd like to
have with Mexico and it was Canada and
of course we would like to have
preferential treatment but this is I
think not the big issue the big issue of
course is how to deal with the fact that
there is not enough gas here on the
continent and as the senator was saying
without all the energy exports out of
the US and the fact that we were able in
nine months to build a huge LNG terminal
in the Netherlands the second one the
Germans opening up now one every week it
seems I see all of Schultz opening up
LNG terminals it seems to be every
weekend is crucial in combination of
course with lowering our dependency on
on fossil and and our and it can also be
done Energy savings in the short term
for the Roman term this is not a
solution for the longer term we have to
get the climate change going the energy
transition including green hydrogen
including new nuclear that will have to
be part of the mix in the longer term
both the green hydrogen backbone as well
as nuclear in the mix state to scale
back nuclear in Europe in your mind
again it was a mistake to scale back
Europe well that is a decision if I say
that I'm criticizing the German
government I'm not going to do that
because it is a national I promised her
to be provocative so and so she's not
challenging me uh but that International
competence Germany but I would not be
amazed if in some work years in the
future I'm not sure about Germany but
many more countries will start to
reinvest the nuclear we will build two
new nuclear reactors because we do feel
it has to be part of our energy mixture
going forward of course it takes years
to build them so for the shorter term at
this LNG it is Energy savings and it is
getting that energy transition going and
then I'm fairly confident that we can
just scrape through and de-leverage our
dependence of Russia which of course we
were forced to do since this horrible
the aggression started against Ukraine
Madam president I'd love if you could
weigh in at this talk to me a bit about
the obligations that you feel the West
has to the global South and I'm talking
about the need for investment and also
in a sense Payback
to your mind where does this leave you
because technically this isn't your
fight
yeah thank you
uh for me I'm first looking at
the sources of the crisis
and here we are talking about
geopolitical
and then climate change
but then geopolitical will always be
there
so I think the lesson we are learning
from that
that we have to diversify sources of
energy
for a long time I think Europe has been
depending on where River they were
depending on but then crisis happened
and now we have crisis in energy so it's
high time to look
to Africa
this High time that Africa could be
another source of energy we have
everything when we talk of green energy
Africa has got everything and Scott Nico
has got Cobalt has got copper so it's
heightened Europe America and others
come and manufacture
extract from Africa manufacture from
Africa and then leave some energy to
Africa and take some to their other
countries but then um
I must say that
for Africa
for us we think we still need funding
um to get energy from gas
of course
we we accept green energy but there has
to be transition proper transition and
who should put the bill for that in your
mind who should foot the bill for that
should that be developed Nations
should it be the private sector
private sector private sector because
it's uh
it's it's a trade and investment so
private sector should come to Africa
extract and produce energy but again
fund for transition fund for transition
because
the reality is Africa now needs a lot a
lot of energy
because the fourth Industrial Revolution
is concentrating in Africa a lot of
investment a lot of manufacturing is
done over there so there is
um a high demand of energy in Africa so
I think the world should look to Africa
now but again in Africa we have learned
our lessons as well whatever we have we
have to concentrate in our
power pools original power poles East
African power poles Southern African
power poles uh we had that policy we
haven't done enough to to create our
power pose so I think if we have the
power poles then there will know the
problem of shortage of energy because
whoever has any crisis the powerful
could serve for the for the region so
that's the lesson I think we will learn
but again I think this is uh
a global problem
and the solution should be globally
multilateralism in solving this problem
because yeah we have seen
um panicking around the world
the superpowers big Powers they are all
coming up with their own policies for
for for getting more energy Americans
have got their own policies
um Europe Japan India they are coming
with different different policies but in
YouTube unilateralism so we think
um
this is a global problem
the globe should solve should have a
effort effort Global effort to solve
this problem so that's what I can say
Francesco went from the private sector
point of view you've heard from the
policy makers does this um
in your mind influence your strategy
going forward because Mr Stormer for
example is talking about an opec-like
organization that would include all of
the European nations as well as the
United Kingdom talking about a cohesive
approach Ms root is saying it's time to
invest in more nuclear as well what to
your mind does this say to the private
sector time to invest yes
sorry
go ahead so I you know I think
if you look at the continuous changes in
policy making around the world you would
really stop doing anything I mean this
would be a on off on off affair with
very little done so you have to look a
little bit at the major
Trends and and the major Trends are very
simple and basic and they've always been
around for something to make sense
it has to be in the money
it has to make economic sense and I like
very much what Senator mentioned just
said you cannot substitute something if
you don't have anything that substitutes
it that is at least equal or better so
that's really the guiding principle for
going long term you have to make choices
that are technologically robust in the
economic sense second clearly you want
to avoid the climate risk
disaster so you have to have that that
light guiding you because you cannot
make long-term bets on This Disaster
that that is in front of us and thirdly
it has to have to do it has to do with
security supply which was maybe a little
bit in the Limelight in the back you
know of our mind a year ago now it's
definitely in the front of a mind of
many many governments so these three
things really guide us and if you look
at what technology is doing in in the
light of these three con parameters
there's lots of things that help and
lots of Investments that make sense and
when you see policies that don't get it
you try and articulate some kind of
response and try to convince the policy
makers and The Regulators you try again
and if it doesn't work you go elsewhere
I mean it's very simple you cannot fight
a government you have to wait till the
government changes or you have to wait
that their mind changes but the world is
large and opportunities for Investments
are everywhere and you know if I if I
can say you know we've been investing in
the US now
more than almost 20 years Okay so we've
seen a lot of different administrations
coming and going and we've seen a trend
that has been characterized by these
three things Investments and renewals
made sense because they were in the
money not because people were friendly
with environment but you know that you
know it's a total departing an issue but
is this investment making money yes it
is so let's do it we would have been
crazy to force it without that guiding
star so I think that's really the point
for a private sector that has a long
term of course there are short-term
Investments that don't require this kind
of articulated thinking but in our case
unfortunately we are on very very long
term so we have to go through this kind
of principles to to drive our strategy
does it concern you as an industry
leader to hear the comments from Mr
Stormer for example that there should be
no new oil and gas investment in the
North Sea because we're talking about
the transition and every Oil and Gas
Energy CEO tells me regularly on CNBC
that to do an orderly transition you
need to continue to invest in spare
capacity and in fossil fuels for
actually I think it is very very
difficult to answer that question
I tell you and and I know many of my
colleagues in the oil and gas businesses
and I respect what they're doing because
it's very very difficult to to
transition
the transition is much faster than
originally estimated and it's going to
accelerate so decisions in that field
risk to be
wrong or right very quickly and that is
a little bit contrary to this industry
track record this is an interesting
track record that goes in decades but
then here
we're talking about ears think what
happened to the gas business in Europe
after the war
all of a sudden we have a seismic change
and we discovered that we could use a
lot less gas not only because it's warm
outside but because we're all of a
sudden understanding how much we were
wasting of it yeah so so I think in that
case I would be kind of careful not to
make bets that go too long in the future
because the future is coming fast
yeah Elam what's the greatest danger in
your mind
um as we move forward with the energy
transition policy makers clearly got a
lot of things wrong ahead of this
horrific invasion of Ukraine and we're
seeing that all playing out now in real
time and over the last 12 months the
same to your mind what does brussels
need to learn from this from a policy
perspective
well a lot has been said I represent the
the chemical industry here is the mother
of all Industries for Brussels and
Europe where the fourth largest industry
in Europe right the oldest one and the
mother of all Industries basically
without chemistry there is no EV battery
there is no green hydrogen there is no
semiconductors
and it's one of the oldest 100 Years of
infrastructure
so in Europe Europe is one of the most
is the most regulated region in the
world
we have the green deal we have the fit
455 which many corporations like ours
have adopted
and there is a cost of decarbonization
for the existing infrastructure let's
not forget the old infrastructure for a
company like Solvay it represents 20 of
our annual revenues right it has a cost
we can do it we're a large company we
believe in it but there are smes small
and medium-sized Enterprises we need
also that our customers they are our
suppliers we need to Embark so the
challenge and then there is the Green
Field right the green you know
Investments like green hydrogen rights
like EV batteries the Airbus of
batteries semiconductors to get our
sovereignty rare Earths we didn't talk
about it 90 of the magnet they come from
China these days right we are in a rare
earth value chain and we need to
localize and unsure the rare earth and
all these Investments have to be
subsidized as well and supported at the
last but not the least just transition
is how to upskill the 20 million
Europeans who needs to be upskilled to
prepare them for the job of tomorrow so
there is one word just one take away
from my speech is competitiveness
Europe has a huge Challenge and huge
risk of de-industrialization Ira is not
the enemy is the best thing which could
happen to Europe is Ira thank you
because Ira I mean we should not get
into the Trap that's Biden is
incentivizing and Europe is over
regulating
and this is where we are today as as an
industry so the question is not I rare
or not the question is what does it take
for Europe to have a competitive
Industrial
infrastructure and policies that's what
we need for the chemical industry again
I need clean energy I need it at cost at
scale 365 5 days a year around our my
site to give you an example we committed
to exit Car Coal by 2030.
I joined the company four years ago it
took me three years to get permitting
but in it's insane
we were ready to pay the money we had
alliances even subsidies the money is
not the problem cash is there but the
permitting and bureaucracy is too heavy
so if there are two cores as a European
as well critical is
we need an industrial policy with
competitiveness at the heart of it let's
talk about an energy Union carbon
pricing we already have it as a company
globally be it in China in the US or in
Europe and the second one is permitting
gets it done quicker is that possible in
your mind prime minister yes and it is
necessary and I'm sorry I I really think
since I've spent a lot of time in
Brussels so you you can you can
always yeah we're always going back to
the Hague but
there is
this inflation reduction Act I agree it
is also opportunity because in Europe
the discussion immediately focus on
getting rid of state-aid rules that we
extremely unwise we have to tune this
data at rules sure very specifically and
targetedly but not get rid of them
secondly we need a big new fund of money
to subsidize our industry so it's
already there are lots of other funds
around we have the European budget we
have the recovery funds Etc so there is
money about
uh what we do not have is a lot of
competitiveness we have a debt to GDP
and some of the biggest economies over
100 we have pension systems which are
really outdated and at this moment
taking out 10 to 15 with GDP is some of
the biggest economies in Europe and that
is those are the things we have to we
have to transform it's crucial uh my
current is now investing 35 billion in
the energy transition because we can
make that money available because we are
only spending five percent of our GDP on
pensions but the most important thing
going back to the thing of this this
panel is the energy transition because
there are large and big opportunities
for companies for Innovation if you do
this in the right way in my country we
have 10 million employment 10 million
people employed I predicted by 2031 to 2
million they'll be employed in new
Industries in Innovative sectors which
will come out of this energy transition
if we do it in the right way and there
we also have to work together as a
European skill I think that's crucial
but competitiveness including bringing
down our debt to GDP and many economies
is crucial otherwise Europe will be the
Museum of the world people coming here
to look at the beautiful buildings and
cities but real stuff will happen in
Asia and the US and I cannot accept that
because this is the best part of the
world to live in not only because of the
museum but also because of our industry
base and our Innovative industry yeah
and this is where I will think of some
Applause for you
it will be helpful think
let me respond basically
the how the IRA came about was because
of the Ukraine war let's be honest
we knew everyone has their desires they
want everything to be clean and green we
all do
but also the real real life sets in and
the realization that you've got to have
dispatchable 24 7 uh in in the country
and all of our countries 24 7 power
dispatchable
okay and up until not long ago we
basically had only coal nuclear then gas
came on and we did it was controversial
but we did fracking tracking Unleashed
an ocean of energy for the United States
we were basically a net importer of
energy we needed we reversed our our
terminals to be exporters we've got six
terminals working out export lngs we got
four more that will come online very
quickly and then we have 10 in a hopper
maybe even a half of those come so
that's where we're going to get to the
2030. so we become a net net expert we
play to our strengths but that it didn't
hit it didn't hit really a nerve until
we saw what Putin did to Ukraine
that's what got me going and when we
were told and and we were told and and
all these high end meetings that we have
secretive meetings and and the skiff we
call it that if you two things are going
to happen in 2022. either Russia would
you know move on Ukraine or China would
move on Taiwan those were the two things
and they gave us the scenarios they
broke it down from a military standpoint
we were told that basically Ukraine
it's not gonna if it does happen it
won't be long maybe a week or two it's
going to be sort of like Crimea so we
had all these set aside we were told
that also inflation wasn't going to be
it's transitory
I didn't think that was true and I told
him I disagreed with him and I didn't
think that Ukraine would roll over God
they didn't thank God for zielinski and
Ukrainian people when all that happened
then Putin weaponized energy then you
also Fair Senator he had been
weaponizing energy for quite some time I
know he has I know he has but it's been
more effective now and it was effective
because he was able to really put a
hurting on all of our allies and here we
are
you know with all these resources and
haven't developed them that's why we did
what we did and I know right now people
are saying well the Market's this is not
protectionism
this is basically Ingenuity at its best
what we're saying is we're and we paid
for that this is not debt financing this
was paid for by 15 corporate tax a lot
of Corporations were not paying a 15
fair share tax we put that in I thought
that was the first thing to do and we
paid for it also we paid two of over 300
billion dollars of our debt we paid down
first time in 30 years paid down debt
produce more energy put more product in
the market that's why it called
inflation reduction if you put more
product in the market you should have
lower prices Senator I feel very bad
about the prices they had to pay had I
mean when on a spot Market you were
paying some of the highest prices of gas
in our LNG that's what we've got to
change we've got to give you a stable
long-term pricing at a more better a
much better price and we can do that
because so many people in Europe have
accused the United States of price
gouging when it comes to gas the market
the market is what the market is price
you know we have a lot of energy
the market needed it the world was
demanding it and that's where the market
went that like the oil market so they
should be able to charge whatever they
feel well they're basically in a market
system unless you want to put caps on
everything and you start putting caps on
things you won't have the product you
need when you need it that's the problem
so what we're talking about now if we
put more product out there we have more
LNG State there'll be more competition
you're going to be able to have you know
you're down about twenty dollars now in
mcf word about basically six dollars
we're used to paying 350 in mcf you paid
60 80
equivalent to an mcf it was ridiculous
my heart my heart hurt for you all but
that part of mine is we can get better
we've got a question for you steal our
thing
right Senator you're widely considered
as a man that actually Republicans can
work with when it comes to energy
hopefully everybody can well does that
mean that you're going to run my main
thing is I don't look at Democrats and
Republicans I don't look at the party
are you on the right or the left I'm an
American party I want my country to be
as strong as it can to help all of our
allies but what about your party are you
going to run in 2024. I have no idea
what I'm going to do in 2024. I really
don't I've been at this for quite some
time but I've never been able to be
pigeonholed I've never been afraid of
losing
that's that's the smallest price I can
pay to do what I think is right Mr star
marks bring you in on this first of all
are you surprised that your prime
minister didn't show up to Davos uh yes
I think I promised I should have showed
up
I absolutely do
um and one of the things that's been
um you know impressed on me since I've
been here is the absence of the United
Kingdom and that's why it's really
important that
um I'm here in the our shadow Chancellor
Rachel Reeves is here as a statement of
intent that should there be a change of
government I hope there will be the
United Kingdom will play its part on the
global stage in a way I think it
probably hasn't in recent years and so
that's my opportunity to say why we're
here I do think the Prime Minister
um should be here having these
discussions having the meetings that
I've been having
um I want to say just a little bit about
the IRA because I think
um it's very easy to sort of retreat
um and to see challenge I actually think
it should be a catalyst for all of us to
say well come on there is a challenge in
relation to the climate crisis that's
been there for a very long time but the
Ukraine conflict has brought that into
sharp focus and we need to stop seeing
it as just a challenge so well it's
actually the single biggest opportunity
we've been given for a very long time to
transition to take the jobs and
opportunities of the future I do think
that that requires a different view of
the state and this is something that
will happen if we have a labor
government in the United Kingdom because
what we want is an active state that is
not saying well look we're going to suck
it all up to the center not saying we're
going to leave it to the private sector
but a state that partners with the
private sector to take these
opportunities and you know one of the
things I'd say about Renewables is look
um we do need to drive down the price
they are you know cheaper in the UK
Renewables are nine times cheaper uh
than oil and gas at the moment it's
economic sense to press forward here to
innovate and make sure that you know an
active State knocks out the barriers
there's no end of businesses that say to
me we could go faster here on the
Renewables but there's bureaucracy
there's planning there's all the things
that get in the way
um and I think in active states where
it's like we partner with that we knock
them out of the way and we drive forward
because the prize here is huge in terms
of energy security and that shouldn't be
something which is National it's in all
of our interests to have energy security
it's in all of our interests to make
sure that Putin can't weaponize Energy
across the world whether it's now or any
time in the future so that's why you
know there's an element of course of
each country trying to rise this
challenge themselves but there is also
an element of mutual cooperation in this
in relation to the mutual threats that
we are facing and that's why I'm very
key to develop this idea of clean power
Alliance which as I say is an inverse
OPEC in the sense that the the purpose
is to drive down those prices across the
globe when you say active State you're
not you're not talking about
nationalizing industry no completely the
opposite so if
um we do come into government
um what changed your mind because I know
at some point in the recent past you
were for nationalizing and
when we when the energy prices went
through the roof in the summer
um we had a good heart thinking about
what because you know consumers families
across the United Kingdom are really
worried because their prices were you
know doubling tripling and there was
already a cost of living crisis and we
looked at the cost of taking energy
companies into public ownership and had
to make a decision do we use such money
as available to pay off the shareholders
so that you can have a publicly owned
asset which does nothing to drive down
bills or do we drive down bills for
people who are struggling to make ends
meet we took the second choice having
looked at those two options and I think
that's the right thing having said that
I think an active State we would create
a vehicle
um Great British energy which would be a
vehicle to take advantage of investment
in cooperation in Renewables as we go
forward so we're very pragmatic approach
to this in the light of a very very
serious cost of living crisis do you
feel that the United Kingdom would be in
the economic hold that it's in right now
had there not been a brexit well they
were still part of Europe I think that
if you look at the United Kingdom
for 13 years the Achilles heel has been
failure to grow the economy and so this
predated brexit brexit made
um that even harder and that's why we've
been making the case for a closer
economic relationship with the EU but
it's not just the EU we've not had a
strategic plan in the United Kingdom for
10 years and if you don't have a
strategic plan it's very hard to attract
investment and if you look at the
investment foreign direct investment
into the UK
under the last Labor government it was
about eight percent now it's about four
percent that is driven by the sense of
instability and drift that there is at
the moment and you know we we burned
through three prime ministers four
chancellors and four budgets in the last
12 months that is that is not though not
the conditions for
um stability and that's why
um it's very important that we make it
clear as an incoming labor government
that stability and economic growth
restoring trust in the institutions that
give that um credibility and Trust the
obr the bank of England is very very
important to the project of ensuring
that uh in that way we can match private
a public uh investment with private
investment and in that way unlock the
huge potential there is I mean the UK
has got brilliant universities brilliant
scientists brilliant Innovation we've
got all the attributes for investment we
just need to create the circumstance the
environment at which we can change
around what I think is the drift and
that drift is that the fact that our
prime minister is not here I think is
evidence of the drift and we intend to
reverse that Francesca
I just wanted to underline one thing
that if you noticed I.E as just public a
report which is called technology
perspective report this report is a
fascinating reading it shows what
happens not to the energy sector but to
the industrial sector of the world as a
result of the transformation of the
energy sector
and that is why the IRA is so cleverly
crafted because if you look closely at
this report and you look at the IRA you
see that the U.S have not only
interpreted
correctly that need to change the energy
systems in a proper way but also to
change the supply chains that the
Industrial Systems we have built in the
last 20 years and the implicit fact that
we all made
that is we want to retain the right to
buy what we want when we want at the
price we want in the quantity we want
and somebody else takes the burden to
invest in the factories manufacture the
stuff and ship it to us and that
fantastic deal
that we made implicitly obviously no one
never negotiated a building but was
taken by China and and other Asian
countries which did that
okay they did that because we
left them the right to do that and and I
think it's a great deal to have unless
you push it to extremes that are
becoming dangerous so I think it is time
to act on that front it's not just the
energy field through energy there is a
change in the industrial systems of the
world this changes and a creative
opportunity to rebalance these value
chains the supply chains of many
industrial goods that requires attention
from the governments and that requires
policies and these policies I mean the
IRA is a great policy clearly it cannot
be replicated in Europe because we don't
have a fiscal Union in Europe as we all
know so we cannot have fiscal levels we
need to have something different but
something needs to be done because this
is the future of the economic
development what to do with the value
chains and the supply chains of the
future industry development the one that
is triggered now and the one that Ira is
addressing which is much larger than
just the energy sector yeah prime
minister yes I just wanted to get back
to Kia Stamos a point of about brexit by
the way we shelved the idea in European
Union about access because successful
implementation of brexit so it has
helped in the EU to stop the debate on
on exits but I do agree with here
starmer on the role of the state I'm
afraid Market liberal I'm a free market
liberal but and there is a goal for the
state particularly in the energy sector
where it comes to regulation but there's
another goal for the state which I would
like to draw our attention to which is
how to finance internationally these
energy Transitions and how to prevent
energy poverty and it has to do with the
100 billion dollar pledge we made
collectively also within the cop system
and it was in the U.N we decided
recently to ramp up our contribution
from 1.3 billion each year to 1.8
billion in climate financing I think
that's crucial so that's also the global
South and other parts of the world can
fully can fully participate and another
issue and also their state is importance
has to do with water because there is a
water security energy Nexus and I just
want to draw your attention to the fact
that
the Netherlands together with Tajikistan
is organizing the International Water
conference in the U.N at the end of
March where we will discuss water and
the role of water not only in having
enough
and of high enough quality but also the
role it has in the energy transition and
insecurity so I invite you all to that
U.N Water conference at the end of March
also on behalf of Tajikistan why
Tajikistan we are a low-lying Delta
country the chicken Switzerland with
mountains Etc so together we cover all
the aspects of water prime minister do
you feel a sense of responsibility for a
bit of the mess that Europe has found
itself in because we're not just talking
about the invasion of Ukraine we're
talking about policies that are at times
confusing conflicting and basically just
don't work
but as a general question that's always
true but I guess you were also alluding
to the fact that we have been so long
depending on Russian gas and there has
been a lot of criticism lately and I
think that is right to a certain extent
and we could have de-leveraged our
dependence regression guests earlier and
we have seen this year how quickly it
how fast this can be done uh by indeed
in in the for the short term importing
LNG but what I do find a bit difficult
is that we are all uh banging Angela
Merkel and and Germany for this fact
because we all in Europe have been
benefiting from cheap Russian gas for so
many years all the European countries
not just Germany but she does bear some
responsibility you know well she must
have won together with a lot and I'm
going to defend her here who after the
Crimea in invasion was able to come to
the Minsk of course the Minsky peace
process which was crucial and Germany is
a big economy but can only do so much
together with friends and those days so
I really I think she took the right
leadership decisions at that moment
um Schroeder
yeah but guess what it's 2005 and what
he did afterwards yeah okay but that
that's an internal German debate that he
was then uh forced chair of the uh of
the guest room whatever and and and
that's something that his party and he
himself have to cope with but a miracle
cannot be held responsible for what
gerstown did between 1998 and 2005 and
and this chairmanship of the guest from
board was from later on
um but in terms of the dependence on
Russian gas Etc I I do take the point
that as a whole of Europe we were a bit
um yeah sitting our chair thinking okay
that's nice we have this cheap gas and
it's helping us fueling our economies we
could have done more earlier but again
this is a collective thing we did uh
wrong this is not something we can just
blame Germany for
um Madam president I want to bring it
back to the fact that Tanzania is on the
front lines of climate change because
we're not just talking about erosion
we're talking about
um flooding we're talking about drought
and these are all things that are
happening to your country in real time
so when the Prime Minister discusses we
should have we should have moved more
quickly we should have gone faster are
you encouraged by what you've heard here
at Davos in terms of the cohesion
between the private sector and the
public sector about the policies because
frankly most of the folks that I speak
to in the global South feel that they're
being left behind
yeah in Tanzania
we know the crisis and we are affected
by the climate change and so we have
decided to change our policies I've been
hearing the discussion here they are
talking about the policies bureaucracies
and all this so knowing that we have to
work with the private sector to mitigate
and adopt the effects of climate change
then we have to change ourselves before
the climate change changes us so we have
to change our policies we have to change
our governance we have to change the way
we perceive things and so uh Tanzania is
ready to
invite
private sector from around the world to
come and work with us we have the
resources and definitely we have the
determination to do so
you mentioned a moment ago uh minerals
Rare Earth minerals and obviously so
many of them concentrated in China
how worrying is it to you as an industry
player that we may or may not see
another geopolitical crisis in the South
China Sea yeah we talk a lot about
energy but metals and rare Earths are
equally important because when we talk
about EV battery battery is what the
generation of batteries we are
commercializing and using today they are
called lion
Lithium-ion batteries so you need
lithium Cobalt nickel and also copper
copper goes to a lot of our magnets Etc
so Frederico said it's China has been
localizing and building their value
chain for decades right 90 90 that the
magnets in the world are being exposed
from China it's very difficult to have
exports on rare Earths we are one of the
few players who can actually separate
Black Mass but we need the Black Mass we
need the the ingredients and it comes
from China Australia now there are a lot
of Junior mining including in the United
States of America in Latin America in
Canada some of them in Africa so
um that diversification and that look at
the value chain is is important because
and I was worrying when I saw the Airbus
of batteries coming to Europe and
onshoring the batteries make up so
assembling batteries it's okay you can
assemble a battery but you need to look
at the secret Source right the the
chemicals the the rare earth and you
need to localize those equally if you do
believe that they are essential to your
future so yeah I think Europe has
started the US definitely is is pushing
on the rare Earth's uh Mining and I
think it's critical and even less than
rarer with without talking off about
copper and other metals so we need those
diversification and that's not fall into
cheap gas Russian soil supplier syndrome
yeah prime minister just a quick one for
you just been in Washington we talk
about Rare Minerals but we also of
course
talk about chips does it bother you that
the White House is trying essentially to
tell you what to do when it comes to
doing business no and they are not and
that's why it's not bothering me there
is
um there is an issue not just between
you us and the United States and Us and
other countries there is an issue around
chips semicon uh when you particularly
talk about a high end so they're very
much Advanced chips technology which can
be used in defense systems for example
there is an issue around keeping the
industry Edge in the Western World in
Europe in the US to make sure that we
keep that
from position in a sense in terms of
chips production particularly
anti-high-ins but at the same time there
is an Irish issue around supply chain
many chips are using cars refrigerators
they are fairly simple and we should not
make decisions which would lead to a
situation where that type of chips will
not get produced and therefore supply
chain will get clocked again as it did
at a high point when the economy was
doing very well so all these issues have
been taken into account we have those
debates with a couple of countries to
make sure that we take care of our
essential security interests that's not
just U.S also others ourselves and the
Netherlands together with the US Japan
others like Germany France is one of the
big players in this industry so it is
only logical that we have that
discussion but I do feel that we can
solve this in in a grown-up manner
together
not necessarily two two ideas that
necessarily mix
um okay Senator Mansion just before we
we wrap things up when you think about
what happens next in the United States I
cover OPEC on a regular basis I was in
Vienna when that decision was made to
cut production today when we look at the
oil Market specifically prices
frankly seeming to reflect that the
Saudis made the right call
in your mind is this a point where the
white house needs to back off Saudi
Arabia
let me just say in the whole concept of
women talk about energy energy
Independence if you have the ability in
your country to be energy independent
you have the resources and to know how
to do it you should do it but you should
do it in the cleanest fashion possible
with a responsibility to carbon
emissions
that doesn't mean eliminate that means
innovate it okay we've done that that's
what this bill challenges you if you
don't have that ability then you better
have a partner that you can trust it'll
always be there philosophically that has
the same love of of the freedom that you
and I have and basically a democracy
that's who you should be dealing with we
let ourselves get in because of either
laziness or the greed one of the two we
found the cheapest and we didn't really
care what they thought and they agreed
or lined up with this politically and we
all got ourselves into a mess
we're trying to correct that in the
United States we want to continue to be
the superpower and the leader and we
can't do it without our with our
European allies and natives we can't
this is all one big family and we've got
to work together so I've said the 117th
Congress that we just came out of the
most divided Congress in over 240 years
of the United States of America
it was the most divided it was one of
the most productive that we've ever seen
why because we knew we had to do
something we're so trying to suggest
that OPEC is holding the U.S hostile oh
OPEC we don't we get eight percent of
our fuel from OPEC 62 percent of our 62
percent of our heavy crude comes from
our dearest trading partner Canada
Alberta
when all this thing came to a crunch and
I saw my Administration my my government
talking about Iran and Venezuela and and
and the Gulf Coast the Gulf area I'm
thinking nobody's talked to the North
Slope nobody's talked to the Permian
base nobody's talked to Alberta that's
when I went crazy that's when I wrote
the Bill and that's when my staff my
energy Chief and my staff we started for
three months nobody knew we were doing
it because I didn't want to go through
what I'd gone through for eight months
when we killed bbp and I didn't want
that type of attention I says they might
never take this but again they might and
it got to the complexion Point
deflection point of where gas prices
were going
and and basically inflation was at nine
percent United States gas prices were
four dollars which are unheard of in the
United States and and we were in a mess
in the president's poll numbers were
here Democratic party president poll
numbers
everybody was desperate to do something
this was the only thing that made sense
that you could do something and we
didn't know it would have this type of
effect this quick but what what happens
when you incentivize people when you say
listen I'm your partner we're going to
basically share the risk
and we did that and they jumped from all
over the world and now everyone says
well that was targeted it wasn't
targeted we want the UK to be as strong
as it can be it's been our dear partner
all of Europe has met all of our allies
but do whatever you can and if it's all
about Renewables God bless you then you
should do it we have both we can do it
all and we have the resource let me tell
you the critical minerals
because we only have four more
Transportation mode very quickly our
transportation mode we were moving and
he wants to be cut off
forgive me but I have to cut you off I
just want to get our panelists um to
weigh in just before we let everyone go
on what they think is the greatest
challenge frankly to the energy
transition today Mr Stormer I I think
the biggest challenge is that whilst we
have moved from
um climate change denial we've got
ourselves into climate change
um delay and that's the biggest
challenge and because of Putin because
of
um everything that happened in 2022
there's a risk that we slide backwards
rather than speed forward I think that's
the single biggest challenge and that
where we need Global Leadership
um and you know it's very important that
we have events like this here at Devils
to have those discussions to show that
leadership and this is my first time at
Davos and I'm told there's always a mood
sometimes it's overly positive sometimes
it's overly negative
um I think this one appears sort of
balanced we know what the challenges are
there's a negativity about that but a
positivity be about where we go from
there and I I suppose my
um sense from it would be and
particularly with an eye on hopefully
what might happen in the United Kingdom
is this sense of dare to Hope as we go
forward prime minister in one sentence
um it's getting the volume
the size of Renewables as such a base
that we are able to make the transition
happen to in in a in a balance with
nuclear I think that's possible but
that's my big worry that we can get
there solar wind and all the other
Alternatives and nuclear enemies
president
oh for me for me what I can say is um
whatever way the world takes
um insisting that we have
to solve this crisis with global efforts
I think everyone has a contribution to
make
one who is having technology the other
one is having the resources the other
one might be having something else so we
all have to put our efforts together to
solve this energy crisis yeah
you know I have spent all my life my
professional life in in energy and I
have to say energy is something
without a purpose
you need energy for something else than
energy itself and I think the lack of
understanding of this factor is I think
the limit of this transition we discuss
a lot about how to generate electricity
with this or that technology that is
already chosen by the evolution of
technology that is not a debate we
should have I think with speech we
should have is what we're using the
energy for what benefits the energy
provides to society how it should be
supplied how it should be distributed
how it should be used that's really the
demand side of energy is totally absent
from the debate and I think it's really
what matters to people and who cares
whether you're producing with this or
that technology at the end of the day
this is just a theoretical debate what
is the purpose of all this why are we
using energy what what why are we
lacking it you know in the case of many
countries here I think that's really the
limit of the transition the lack of the
perspective on demand ilham
to add to all of this for me it's about
the alignments between the different key
stakeholders
um and I'll take the example of the EU
is 27 member states
they all have different energy sources
the north has been blessed with Hydro
the South with solar France believes in
nuclear beats we are agnostic to death
but we need an energy Union with
Diversified sourcing if Europe wants
really to become competitive so that's
alignment and then a really
co-construction with the industry we
need to be in the room not because we
want to be in the room it's just because
that's our job to to to manage how to do
it you know if you over regulate and say
why how and when you're gonna fail and
we should not plan to fail we should
plan to win and back casting from the
green deal and carbon neutrality is
extremely important so that's private
public
alliances and partnership are critical
Senator thank you
[Laughter]
I just want to say thank you to the
world economic Forum thanks Hadley for
having this very informative and I'm
walking away with much more knowledge
and much more optimism and much more
challenges but also I see where success
can be too but thank you all as we hope
you all do thank you so much for joining
us
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]